in December 2022 the most far-right
government in Israel's history came to
power notable inclusions are national
security minister Ben gavier previously
convicted of supporting a terrorist
organization and Finance Minister bezel
SMD a settler well known for racist
comments and extreme
policies they quickly approved plans to
build thousands of homes for Israeli
settlers in the occupied West Bank
construction that's illegal under
international law War the new policy led
to an increase in Israeli raids and
attacks by both Israeli settlers and
Palestinian Fighters these are scenes
from hawara in
February hundreds of Israelis from a
nearby settlement went on a rampage
through the town of 8,000 Palestinians
after two settlers were gunned downridge
called for haara to be
erased H was targeted again on Friday
Israeli set shot a resident in the heart
after a Palestinian gunman opened fire
at an Israeli
vehicle Palestinian armed resistance has
increased since March last year after
Israel's incursion at alaka mosque and
renewed raids on the occupied West Bank
and
Gaza Israel has repeatedly said it will
root out these
fighters in early July it launched a
two-day assault in Janine refugee camp
in the occupied West
Bank more than 3,000 Palestinians fled
the air strikes bulldozers armored tanks
and drones and this was the
result Janine's Deputy Governor said 80%
of the homes in the camp were destroyed
damaged or
[Music]
burned attacks or raids take place in
occupied territories nearly every
day in April Israeli forces attacked
Muslim worshippers in alaka mosque
during Ramadan
prayers an action the UN condemned as
excessive and in recent days thousands
of ultra nationalist Jews have been
entering the mosque compound escorted by
Israeli police a move condemned by the
Jordanian wak the custodians of the
mosque Hamas officials have long said
they will respond to Israel at a time
and place of their choosing
but Saturday's attack seemed to take
many by
surprise Laura Khan Al
jazer make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer